consider the the religious rituals that
have come about just in the last few
weeks that the main one being the mask
you know the mask mask which we were
initially told don't wear the masks the
masks are bad the masks aren't gonna
stop coronavirus we have very little
evidence that the masks do anything at
all then we were told the masks will
protect us then we were told the masks
won't protect us but it'll protect other
people now we're being told something in
the middle and now increasingly we're
seeing people not wearing the masks
properly but just having to have them
around as a virtue signal as a sign that
we're on the right side of the ideology
well Joe Biden is just said if he's
elected president he will completely
unconstitutionally mandate masks at the
federal level if you became president
tomorrow what would you do differently
regarding the pandemic and getting these
surging cases now under control I would
go back to making sure that everybody
had masks that you had PPE lined up we
have been making sure we stockpile all
the things that we need that we don't
have now the one thing we do know these
masks make a gigantic difference I would
insist that everybody on public be
wearing that mask and he want to reopen
it would have to make sure that they
walked into a business that had masks
did you use your federal leverage to
mandate that though yes and you would
you yes I would from an executive
standpoint yes I would so you would in
effect mandate the wearing of matters
that do everything I'm not possible to
make it make it required the people had
to wear masks in public I would do
everything in my possible and I would so
he realizes at the end because Biden's
been around a long time he realized this
wait a second I just said that I would
mandate masks from the federal level but
I probably don't have the constitutional
power to do that so I would do
everything am I possible one thing to
note here is the man still can't form an
English sentence even though they're
they're limiting on the campaign his
public appearances every time he appears
it's clear this guy is not there he is
not with it and and he falls apart even
at the end here but at the broader level
what he's saying isn't true we don't
know that the masks are SuperDuper
effective in fact all the same people
were telling us they weren't effective
just a few weeks ago we don't we know
very little about the mask and we know
that
Joe Biden himself when he was giving a
speech just a couple weeks ago he had
the mask dangling from his ear it wasn't
on his mouth so it wasn't preventing the
spread of coronavirus but it wasn't off
either because if it's off then it he's
not on board he's he wore it dangling
down from his ear just to show people
that he's on the right team people do
this now when you're on an airplane I've
taken a couple airplanes in the last few
weeks or when you're in a restaurant or
something you'll see people wearing the
mask below the nose I guess this is what
I do as well and you wear it below the
nose because it this is extremely stupid
the this this constantly changing
standard wear you have to wear the mask
you don't have to wear the mask
coronavirus is super deadly but go out
and tear down statues and riot for BLM
and and and show up at pride right so
that's not not really based on science
but you have to have it somewhere right
I was on an airplane and I had the mask
I'm not gonna wear a mask on my face for
five hours I'm just not gonna do it and
so I had the mask under my on my chin
right so my mouth and my nose completely
exposed and then eventually I said this
is stupid so I just take the mask off
and the stewardess walks up to me says
you have to put your mask on so I put it
back on my chin obviously not doing
anything to stop any of my air coming
out which is okay that's good it's like
wearing a Mantia in church or a hijab or
wearing a yarmulke if you're Jewish
it is a quasi religious symbol saying
that we are all on board in the same
metaphysics and the invisible enemy that
we're all fighting
[Music]
[Music]